today spacex is known for a multitude of
massive accomplishments from landing
boosters and
constructing starlink to bringing crude
launches back to america
and sending people to the iss despite
all of this at the heart of spacex there
has always been
one core goal which is reaching mars
starting with just planning on sending
mice to mars
and calling it a day to now aiming to
terraform mars
so here's the evolution of musk's mars
vision
over the years
starting off elon musk's yearning to
accomplish something bigger than life
would really start to take shape on his
30th birthday when he turned 30
he realized that he was no longer as
young as he thought he was
reports suggest that elon musk told his
wife at the time
justine quote i'm no longer a child
prodigy
however despite this rather recent
realization
elon musk wouldn't delve into anything
super big or ambitious
just yet he had a pretty good gig at
paypal as the ceo
and paypal was growing quite rapidly but
this would change when musk got fired
from paypal
at this point i'm sure a little bit of
rage from getting fired
really helped him make the jump into
something as crazy as space travel
he was actually also considering going
into solar
but he later revealed that he wasn't
sure how to make solar profitable
at the time when elon musk started
talking about space with his friends
and family many of them actually thought
he was talking about getting into office
space
and then they realized he was actually
just crazy
during this discovery phase he still
wasn't sure what exactly he wanted to do
in space
so he saw conversations with several
other like-minded people
in the industry one such interaction was
with the nonprofit group the mars
society
as the name suggests this was a group of
space super enthusiasts
who wanted to propel the journey in
reaching and
colonizing mars elon musk found out that
the mars society was holding a
fundraiser event
that charged 500 to participate to catch
the attention of the group
musk would go ahead and write a check
for 10 times that
at 5 000 as he hoped robert zubrin
the leader of the group would take
notice and invite elon musk to his house
to have a private conversation
right before the official event during
this conversation
robert would reveal how the mars society
had made progress in sending mice into
space
thus far they had conducted several
experiments with mice
in the arctic that was intended to
recreate the conditions
on mars and the plan was to send the
mice into space in a spinning capsule
which would ideally create an artificial
gravitational force
that is one-third of hertz or the same
as mars
after this conversation robert would
introduce musk to many of the top voices
in the group
such as director james cameron at the
actual fundraiser event
following this experience elon musk
would start digesting
everything he had heard and it wouldn't
take him long to take their ideas to the
next level
his original idea was to upscale the
mice project
instead of sending a mice colony to
space why not just send them straight to
mars
musk would pitch the newfound idea to
many of the contacts that he had made
through the mars society
and considering that they were all space
enthusiasts as well
they actually thought it was feasible
with about 20 million dollars
with that elon musk would start his own
organization
called the life to mars foundation he
wasn't exactly looking to start a large
kill business
or anything along those lines he simply
thought that sending mice to mars would
reignite the public interest
in space exploration and colonization
and that this renewed interest would get
the big boys like nasa
and ross cosmos to start pursuing mars
seriously
after a couple of life to mars
foundation meetings however the idea
would morph into what is now known as
the mars oasis project this idea
suggested launching a small
self-sustainable greenhouse to mars
instead of mice
scientists had already made progress on
such a greenhouse
and the group thought that it was for
the most part feasible in a couple of
years
maybe 2004 or 2005.
there were some members who objected
citing that such a project would
actually cost closer to 200 million
dollars
however the society often overlooks such
criticism
determined to make this vision a reality
musk would embark on his famous trip to
russia
to negotiate the purchase of some
refurbished icbms
the plan was to purchase three icbms for
20 million dollars total
or about 6.6 million dollars each the
russians offer was actually pretty close
to that amount
coming in at 8 million dollars per icbm
but musk wouldn't have it and would call
off the meeting
on the trip home he would propose
building their own rocket
and this is when a strong support base
would basically just evaporate away
many of the leaders in the group like
robert zubrin had seen several similar
efforts
utterly fail as a result when musk
proposed building rockets
most of the group signed off on musk and
understandably so
he could have simply purchased the icbms
from the russians
and sent mice to space for tens of
millions but
now he was looking to spend hundreds of
millions on rocket development
which had a high probability of simply
going nowhere
despite this overwhelmingly negative
sentiment musk would go ahead and
establish spacex
anyways in mid-2002 and here's what he
planned
he wanted to develop the first engine
within the first year by may 2003
following this he wanted the second
engine done by june of 2003.
july of 2003 would be dedicated to
assembling the body of the rocket
and the first launch would take place in
november 2003
after this a mars plan was slated to
happen by the end of the decade
or at least that was a plan in reality
it would take up until fall of 2004 for
them to just finish the first engine
or the merlin engine on the bright side
though the merlin engine was one of the
most efficient rocket engines in history
so though it was taking much longer than
anticipated
the development did look quite promising
it would nonetheless take until late
before spacex would succeed in launching
the falcon 1 into orbit
following this success spacex would win
a contract from nasa
to supply the iss worth over one billion
dollars
and this would be the turning point at
which spacex could shift their focus
from survival
to mars once again soon after in 2010
spacex would launch their first falcon 9
and
elon musk would announce the falcon
heavy in 2011.
the falcon heavy was originally slated
to be the gateway to mars as
it was expected to be able to carry 16
800 kilograms to mars
the idea was really quite simple they
got the falcon 9 working already
so why not just lap three falcon 9
boosters together to allow for greater
pillow to be delivered
deep into space quite simple in theory
but in practice this turned out to be
much harder than originally anticipated
originally the plan was falcon heavy
launching by 2013
and they could start doing supply runs
to mars in the second half of the decade
they weren't quite sure if they wanted
to use falcon heavy for crude missions
to mars
but it did seem like a good choice at
least for supply runs
this was also the time period in which
musk would get his idea
to nuke mars the idea entails launching
controlled nuclear missiles at mars
which would explode in the martian
atmosphere these explosions would
essentially create short-term heat
sources
which will in turn melt the ice at mars
polar caps
the melting of the ice would release co2
into the martian atmosphere
and as we all know excessive co2
emissions
cause global warming so really elon musk
plans to artificially start global
warming on mars
by nuking it critics of the idea have
suggested that such a plan would require
at least 10 thousand missiles to which
elon musk replied
no problem despite these lofty goals
unfortunately
a falcon heavy launch wouldn't
materialize up until 2018
and by that point spacex had already
started working
on the bfr or the starship rocket and
this brings us to the stage that we were
in for the last couple of years
the plan was for starship to be used for
uncrewed supply runs throughout 2022
and a crude mission would take place in
however in october this too was pushed
back
starship has been making incredible
progress so far
but it's by no means ready to go to mars
or
even the moon at this point as it's
still very much in the early stages of
development
the most recent timeline proposed by
elon musk is
unclear supply runs to mars using
starship in 2024
and crude missions starting in 2026.
i'm not quite sure these dates will pan
out either
but given the serious progress with
starship and the fact that spacex is
mostly in the green for survival
as they have established themselves as a
reliable commercial launcher as well as
starlink
i think a crude mars mission by the end
of this decade is quite possible
at the end of the day elon musk
basically had a mid-life crisis
at 30 years old which made him wander
into the space community
the original idea was to simply send
mice to mars by 2004
but now we're looking at launching 10
000 nuclear missiles
at mars in all seriousness though those
were the various stages
of elon's mars vision and today we think
we're finally on the cusp of making it a
reality
but we'll just have to wait and see do
you guys think starship is the key to
mars
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys are excited to finally put
people
on mars and of course consider joining
our discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you